we're moving our feet we're competing
at a high level we got energy in here
energy on the bench energy on the ice
that drives the physicality we're more
alert we're more aware and our game just
comes together here on the road in the
start of a great trip C Lilly will go for
us on the back JT with nce and Willie Sammy
kicking a great atmosphere electricity in the
air here at Emir Bank Arena been waiting for
this one it was so fun playing in front of
these fans the energy that they had for us
all of last year and coming into this season has
been amazing all right on the left we got swaggy
swag in the middle we got the Swiss Army KNE
on the right we got Chucky on the back we have
Meeks the other back we got coie and in the
net we have Bobby the Panthers playing their
home opener and it's a rematch of last season's
second round playoff series against the Toronto
Maple Leafs I think it's easy to get hung up
on the past cousins closing shooting scores
Nick cousins wins the series obviously you
know it's always in the back of your mind
the previous playoff uh stuff but uh in the
end it's you know you're focus on today and
and the here and now four consecutive years the
Panthers have made the Stanley Cup playoffs and
they're the Eastern Conference champions there's
a new ban in the house let's go wakey wakey wake
come on and we are underway yeah yeah take him
take [Music] him now really uh good friend of
mine you know play with him at the US team and
you know World Juniors and to see him do what
he's doing it's very very impressive and proud
of him he's done a great job and he's off to
another hell of a start this year we got to get
to the inside too much on the outside already
boys he's an extremely effective
talented player and uh he does a
lot of uh really great things for for
his team you know in a lot of different
ways so he's always a challenge
to playing in quick go go hold
hold it's a battle for that loose Puck it's kept
to the outside by kingberg giv away right Circle
a shot and they score yeah and it's Kevin
stanlin with a heavy R shot out of the right
Circle and the Panthers are on the board final
seconds see how they're doing this behind the
net boys barov looking to give someone a chance
Atman LaRon shoots and scores o e l two nothing
Panthers [Applause] yes hard boys hard go go let's
get H physical here hey come on get physical you
three get physical finish finish him move that
move that good work boys keep working let's go
shoot some Puck here get the Pucks in that Call's
crashing DD Rim I'll take care Miner's back of
the net finds nander in front for tarus the
shot right now the back hand scores mner right
boys and the Maple Leafs are on the board that's
it the races now is looks ahead to Gregor busting
it on binsz Gregor penalty coming now the Nets
off Le thought that might be a penalty shot no
he's with you the whole way yeah no he's with
you the whole way though but if you break away
then yeah like if you get a step on him but
I don't think you had a step I want to make
sure that the puck doesn't go in the normal
positions of the post here as a result of
Florida knocking the net off yeah this is a
better angle to see if the puck is going to
go in the net here as a result I don't think it
does okay we're good upon further video review
the call in the ice stands we have no goal
and we have a penalty for tripping against
Florida 21 Panther lead should be a great third
period you got nothing I'm going to try to get
open for in the corner I'll jump off the net need
a kill this boys shoot Koski makes the stop on we
got to win those there we need that puck we
need that puck you got it I think if I have
to a little bit like just spread out a little
bit so I can bump like I did then we can spre
him out and work it now another a chance on the
side of the go Browski turns it away from Marr
yeah if you're going to if you're going to spin
shoot it to the net on a cut back on forehand
shoot it to the net that's probably the best game
that we've played in in terms of the quality of
the game it was it was tight it was fast it was
competitive back for Mar a chance for to at the
Go post I know what you're trying to do but he's
right there and you make a left and make a right
I have of him shut it down didn't do enough uh to
to generate enough offense so you don't score you
don't win that's way way way it works side M 5
seconds and rard broke it up the line Reinhardt
Fires at the distance and it's in the net he
scores As Time expires hug hug hug hug I was
I was really looking forward to this one um all
summer since uh since the finals and the Panthers
knock off the leaps here on the home opener that's
it s hey love you Bob unreal awesome it felt very
similar to a playoff type win um that we had
all last spring especially against these guys
that uh it felt good ahead of us in the standings
in our division so um yeah this one feels pretty
good